I have the belief that all humans are
addicted the question is what are we
addicted to I am addicted to the
dopamine Rush that I get or the
serotonin whatever from lots of grit and
then payoff right understand that cycle
well and so I like to play it as many
times as I can you get the most amount
of gains in a new skill in the first 20
hours like learning it you want to learn
the guitar you want to learn sing you
want to learn a cold call first 20 hours
the problem is that people will wait
years to start the first hour because
they're so afraid of that of the pain of
not being good enough some of this 7
million that you're talking about also
have an addiction but they got addicted
to something that was not pro-social or
it's not per work and so to your point
about the video games in the basement
they are addicted to that and they do
get dopamine in a way that is superior
to anything that happens in the real
world and it's being enabled by the
parents that continue to subsidize that
addiction